remember a few years ago they started
telling us that actually sex differences
weren't real and you thought you said
well i took biology i know that
men and women are physical categories
and i am one so i kind of know it's true
and they relax
it's only about being sensitive to a
small percentage of the population who
are different you don't want to judge
them you're not a bigot are you and you
think yourself no i'm kind of liberal
minded i want to bother other people
live how they want to live
it's like it's going to affect my life
oh but it is going to affect your life
in fact it's going to reorder society
completely here's the latest example of
it at the university of pennsylvania a
biological man has decided to say that
he's a woman he's a swimmer
and he's destroyed
the women's swimming records of course
because he's a man actually
the swimmer goes by the name of leah
thomas competed for three years as a man
before he decided to identify as a woman
in a recent women's competition he just
won a 500 yard freestyle by a full
14 seconds now if you swim right into a
swimming 14 seconds
that's time enough to get a beer and
come back like that there's no 14 second
differences between swimmers but there
are now
thomas's closest rival in a longer fee
style race was
38 seconds behind that's a different
country
so one person who actually did predict
this at great personal cost she's really
hated for saying it but she was right
is karadanski the author of the
abolition of sex the president of the
u.s chapter of the women's human rights
campaign
long-time card-carrying member of the
american left but a very brave person
karadanski joins us tonight cara thanks
so much for coming on you must feel a
little vindicated because when we first
started having these conversations years
ago
you predicted things like this and
people attacked you for being crazy
thank you so much for having me and and
yes i mean a lot of us saw this coming
down the pike there's a woman named beth
stelzer who founded an organization
called save women sports several years
ago she's going to be speaking with your
colleague laura ingram later tonight
many of us saw this coming and it's just
very important that we all understand
that situations like what we're seeing
in pennsylvania at the university of
pennsylvania
are not anomalous this is happening all
over the country as as i know you know
well it's just amazing that people put
up with it i mean if you if you've been
a swimmer had kids who swim 38 seconds
doesn't happen in competitive swimming
that's not even that's a different sport
so this is totally up ended a sport that
we've had for you know over 100 years in
this country where are all the parents
the coaches the swimmers like why isn't
anybody saying anything
a lot of people are saying things a lot
of parents are speaking out i think a
lot of students are very scared of
speaking out because saying look this
isn't appropriate we shouldn't have men
competing in women's sports is a very
unpopular thing to say the other thing i
just want to say is very often this is
framed as having so-called transgender
athletes participating in women's sports
and i really want us to get away from
that language the truth of the matter is
that he is a man and he's been allowed
to compete in women's sports part of the
problem is that a lot of this is
happening because of a series of orders
that the biden administration issued
over the course of the first six months
of the administration impacting title ix
among other federal administrative laws
and it essentially says that throughout
federal administrative law the word sex
has to be redefined to include the words
gender identity and that is a disaster
for women and girls including the women
who are on the upenn women's swimming
team yeah well it just eliminates women
and girls as a meaningful category like
they don't exist anymore so how can you
undo this i mean let's be honest you you
cover this stuff i i'm from washington
like you you change something like that
no one ever changes it back right
well so there is currently a lawsuit
pending that was filed by 20 states and
i'm proud to say that the u.s chapter of
the women's human rights campaign
submitted a brief in that case arguing
that redefining sex to include the
nebulous nonsensical concept of gender
identity also constitutes sex
discrimination and so i'm very happy to
be involved in that lawsuit but i also
just want to note that what i unpack in
the book shows that this goes far beyond
sports so we're seeing for example and
we've talked about this before too
states like california washington and
other states across the country are
allowing convicted male rapists and
murderers to be housed in women's
prisons on the basis of their so-called
gender identity we're seeing the total
invasion of women's spaces prisons
bathrooms locker rooms changing rooms
and sports by men on the basis of their
so-called female gender identity and
what i really want everyone to
understand is that words like gender
identity don't have any meaning they
really don't i mean they're defined
variously inconsistently and um
vaguely in ways that don't make any
sense every single human being is either
a male person or a female person
everything else is a lie
man i i if you ever have an hour i'd
love to sit down and just hear what your
life has been like since you started
saying obvious truths like that uh on
television i think you paid a big cost i
would love to hear about it at some
point anyway in the meantime thank you i
could just make one plea yeah i have can
i make one please four viewers okay so i
have one plea to make which is this as
tucker knows i'm a registered democrat
as he said in my introduction i have
made common cause with many republicans
who are fighting back against so-called
gender identity ideology one thing that
has frustrated me is that across the
political spectrum people still seem to
be of the view that the phrase
transgender people the phrase
transgender athlete the phrase
transgender student the phrase
transgender prisoner has some sort of
coherent meaning it doesn't and so my
plea to your viewers in particular i
know that it's republicans who are
holding the line i don't like it but i
know it's true republicans are holding
the line on material reality all of that
goes out the window when you use a word
like transgender it just doesn't exist
and i'm sorry i'm begging viewers to
stop using it thank you so much the
language matters karadanski thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else